when I woke up this morning I had emails
about address on Twitter and I was bit
bemused about this because I don't use
Twitter by often and I look at the dress
and people were saying there's a huge
discussion of what color it is and I
think well that's nonsense because the
dress is clearly white and gold this is
a dress and this is this is basically a
recreation of the actual picture such as
to print out and to me this morning this
dress is white and gold and I've got a
friend telling me this dress isn't white
and gold it's obviously blue and black
and then I go online and realize for
everyone else it's also deterministic
debate everywhere news sites are
covering it it's all over Twitter and it
seems that close to half the people see
this dress when they first look at it as
white with gold trim and half the people
see it as blue and black lace and what's
even more weird is throughout the day
my brain has also changed and now I see
it is blue when this morning I saw is
white there are two things we can do we
can actually read the pixel values and
find out exactly what color this
particular image is and we can also
perhaps have a look a little bit at the
sort of neurology behind why people see
this differently not to critique too
strongly but this is not a great
photograph there's a few problems with
white balance and with exposure and I
think that's probably one of the reasons
it's causing so much of a problem so
without knowing what the original dress
looks like we presented with this image
and we make a decision as to what kind
of theme we're looking at we will make
an evaluation of what the ambient
lighting condition is and then we'll use
that to work out what color the actual
object is we're looking at and that
helps us basically achieve color
constancy in different illumination
conditions so we've all had this
situation where we might walk outside
and the lighting changes and just for a
minute things look a little bit odd and
then they go away and it's just like
this with this picture so some of us
will look at this picture and see a
white dress in blue illumination so they
think that the blue the scene is fairly
blue but light hitting this dress is
blue and so because the white dress is
going to give up a slightly blue tinge
and other people will be looking at this
dress and seeing a fairly yellow scene
so down here in this area there's quite
a lot of yellow light and we're saying
that this is a blue dress being hit by
yellow light which is not having too
much of an effect so we still see a blue
dress and it's particularly the case
with this black trim here that a lot of
people see this is black with yellow
light hitting it which gives it a kind
of gold Sheen
some people just see it as gold because
the light is not having that effect and
the two people can go out to different
people can go either way on it
one way for finding out what color this
particular dress is in this image is to
literally look at the pixel values and
read them so if we do that for this top
region we get a very clear brown area so
in fact this particular part of the
image is brown okay it's not yellow it's
not gold and it's not black so rather
than sampling one pixel because there's
sort of shadows here and speckle
illumination problems we take a small
region and then we blur it to get rid of
any sort of irregularities and shadows
and we take the average value then the
reading I get for this is 112 red and 96
green and 58 blue so this is slightly
more red than it is blue but it's
certainly not black and it's certainly
not red so it's kind of brownish a
little bit orange maybe so if we do the
same thing to be top area of this dress
we get a value of 129 red 144 green and
180 blue so this is definitely blue
numerically the pixels are more blue
than they are red or green but they're
not strongly blue because we have still
have quite high values so it's quite
washed out and that's another aspect of
this image which is you know less than
desirable objectively in this image this
dress is blue not white but obviously
some people are perceiving it to be
white with a blue light and that would
cause it to appear to us to be blue in
actual fact it turns out this dress is
actually dark blue which gives you some
indication of just how bad the exposure
is on its image lots of people are
looking at this image and going one way
and lots of people are going the other
way and that's why it's so divisive is
that it seems that the sort of the
illumination is in this scene is very
hard to gauge and some people are
judging it to be blue and some people
are judging it to be more yellow this
kind of optical illusion can be seen
elsewhere and this is a good example of
it so in this cube we have a situation
where this orange square here and this
brown square here are actually exactly
the same intensity and this is happening
because on the darker side we're seeing
this orange square is blight compared to
its neighbours and we judge that it must
be a fairly bright color and on the up
side we see it as dark compared to its
neighbors and judge well it must be a
dark color when in fact they're the same
color and we just is how we perceive the
illumination on the
so this kind of thing happens in day to
day life quite a lot but of course in
this case it's sort of come to
everyone's attention because it's just
right on the line between being obvious
and not obvious and everyone's got
extremely confused what if somebody
still seeing white gold doesn't believe
you at all how could there may be reset
there well I just stared at it for a
long time so maybe that would help or
yes it may be but just that's how their
brains wired and they may not be able to
see it as blue and black for you know
for an indefinite amount of time it may
just be how it is for them so I wouldn't
worry too much about it and I would
probably just get on with the rest of
your day
yes oh this morning I saw it as white
and gold I now see it as blue and black
and my meeting of the pixels tells me
it's actually blue and brown in this
image